Speaker 1: OK, one more story having to do
with Joe Manchin killing the build back better
legislation this week.
We have to talk about how the squad was actually
proven right and centrist Democrats were proven
wrong, at least when it comes to one important
aspect of all of this.
A few weeks ago, when the physical infrastructure
deal was being debated, there were several
members of Congress, the progressive Democrats
specifically who urged House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi and Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
to couple the infrastructure deal with the
multitrillion dollar spending bill build back
better and indeed, for a few weeks.
Those two bills were coupled together, and
the idea was that Manchin in some of these
other centrist Democrats, they're sure yeses
on physical infrastructure.
They definitely want to see that get passed.
But when it comes to the multitrillion dollar
spending plan, we just can't trust them.
They they seem to be changing their minds.
And, you know, we just don't know if they're
sure yeses.
Eventually, Nancy Pelosi decided to cave to
the moderates in the party, and they decided
to separate the two bills.
And Biden gave her the stamp of approval to
do so, saying that we're going to be able
to assure that Joe Manchin is going to vote
yes on both pieces of legislation.
So Joe Biden, he essentially gave us his word
on that.
But the squad, they weren't buying it.
So when it came time to actually vote on the
infrastructure deal in November, most of the
Congressional Progressive Caucus, they decided
to vote.
Yes, that's Pramila Jayapal, Katie Porter,
Ro Khanna and a bunch of other familiar names.
But this the six squad members, they held
firm and they voted no.
That's Jamaal Bowman.
Cori Bush.
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez, Ilhan Omar, Ayanna
Pressley and Rashida Tlaib.
And they voted no.
Not because they don't want to see infrastructure
get passed.
That's actually quite the opposite.
They definitely are in support of revamping
American infrastructure, but they viewed this
as the best bargaining chip that they had.
Are making sure that both of the bills got
passed, the physical infrastructure and the
so-called human infrastructure.
And at the time, there was a sentiment among
many Democrats that was like, Look, let's
get infrastructure done.
Biden hasn't had a significant legislative
achievement in a while, maybe not since the
COVID stimulus plan was passed back in March.
And we also don't know if we're going to be
able to, in the long term, maintain the 60
vote threshold that we need in the Senate
to get this passed because you really can't
trust Republicans, like maybe they'll decide
they don't want to support this thing anymore.
The idea was, let's get it done now.
We'll get this round of positive press coverage
about the infrastructure deal.
And then before the end of the year, we'll
get build back better done through budget
reconciliation.
And that will prompt another round of positive
media coverage and will be viewed as yet another
accomplishment for Joe Biden and the Democrats.
Obviously, that didn't play out, and the squad
was right to question mansion's willingness
to go along with the rest of the party.
We actually have a video now of Pramila Jayapal
talking to Maggie Hassan about everything
that went on, and she maintains that she has
no regrets in all of this.
But I sort of doubt that.
Let's take a look at the video and then we'll
come back.
Speaker 3: How do you feel about that today?
Do you feel that Joe Biden let you down?
And do you feel you got played by Joe Manchin?
Speaker 4: No, and no, we are, you know, for
the weeks and the days going up to the vote
in the House, everybody every day, if I had
counted, I would be if I got a penny for every
time somebody said to me This is not going
to happen, you all have given up everything.
We got it done in the house.
Now I am in the same place in saying that
we are getting grenades rolled off us all
the time.
We have to pick them up.
We have to put the pin back in and we have
to continue to focus on the fact that this
is going to be rocky.
We can't hang our, you know, our commitments
and our hopes on the words of one senator
or two senators.
We have to continue to work to get it done
and the vast majority of it is done.
And so I was on the phone with Senator Schumer
today with the White House, and I believe
we will still get it done.
It's going to be rocky and we just have to
continue to leave no space in the in the commitment
to getting it done.
And listen, the president's word is on the
line here and I do still believe that he is
going to do what he told me and what he told
our caucus and what he told the country he
would do.
Had we not done what we had done, though,
and if he doesn't, congresswoman.
What was up?
And if he doesn't?
No, we're going to do it.
We're going to do it, and the leverage
Speaker 3: that you had, your critics would
argue, was lost when you voted for before.
I just wonder, do you regret voting for the
Biff deal now in hindsight, given it's now
months later?
And Joe Manchin is no closer to signing off
on a one point seventy five trillion.
Speaker 4: No, I don't regret it because I
think our leverage was at the maximum point.
Speaker 1: On the other side of the coin,
we have one of the squad members, AOC tweeting
about this, saying quote when a handful of
us in the House warned this would happen if
Democratic leaders gave Manchin everything
he wanted.
First, by moving bef, that's the bipartisan
infrastructure framework before build back
better instead of passing together.
Many ridiculed our position.
Maybe they'll believe us next time, or maybe
people will just keep calling us naive.
And unfortunately, given the Establishment
Democrats track record on all of this and
when it comes to them trying to listen to
progressives, it'll probably be the second
one of those two options there, and they'll
probably just keep getting calls naive.
But there is a counter argument to all of
this that we have to consider as well, and
it is a strong one, which is that even if
the entire progressive caucus held firm and
they prevented the infrastructure deal from
getting passed in the House, and they made
sure that it was only going to happen in one
piece of legislation, the two bills had to
be put together, and that was it.
Are we sure that Joe Manchin would have actually
voted for it?
Like, the argument is that he would write
because he supports the infrastructure deal
in West Virginia desperately needs new infrastructure,
but he just as easily could have done the
same exact thing here.
He could have said, You know, I like some
pieces of this legislation.
I like the infrastructure stuff, but there
are members of my party who are trying to
poison pill it with all of this other nonsense.
And there was this opportunity to make this
bill bipartisan and the progressives are ruining
that opportunity.
So I just can't support this bill in any form
that also could have happened.
That also is a legitimate possibility.
And then progressives, at the end of the day,
they look bad because they are the ones who
are blamed for not allowing infrastructure
to pass when even some centrist Republicans
are willing to do it.
And you have the remainder of the Democratic
Party in support of it.
So what we know for now is that the squad
was definitely right not to trust Joe Manchin,
not to trust his word because his word means
nothing.
But whether or not we actually would have
been able to get both of these things passed
by the end of the year.
That remains uncertain.
And to be honest, I guess we'll never truly
know.
It's sort of an falsifiable in a sense, because
it really just comes down to what Joe Manchin
is thinking on any particular day.
And that's unfortunately what we have to deal
with.
So that's everything having to do with build
back better as of now.
We're going to go to a break back after this.